[Musik]
ok hallo leute ich wieder eure mailand
bei der letzte tick hat wirklich spaß
gemacht hat und ziemlich lecker war
dachte ich mir
hätten wir heute viele verschiedene
tätigkeiten keine mit karamell popcorn
an und zwar mit mehr noch den ganzen
popcorn eigentlich ist aber nicht alles
richtig fette cara menschen älter sind
die lecker schmeckt ob man diese muss
flüssig gemacht hätte und einfach
popcorn rhein geworfen und dann noch
eins drauf gepackt
aufgefallen ist die ganze zeit nur am
essen banal was doch wir alle noch nicht
kennen
caramel cola auch finnland muri bin ich
sehr gespannt weil wir ihn auch - rote
jacke aus amerika was aber nicht nach
einer krippe schmeckt sondern nach
erdbeere konsistent sind sie auf jeden
fall eine rote lack hitze haben wir mehr
erwartet aber der elefanten als nächste
haben wir ein pet airways also 1 1 mit
karamell gefühlt und ich glaube das wird
richtig 13 ich bringe beratung bereit
okay das ist wirklich sehr flüssiges
karamell mein gott das ganze auf karamel
gefühl liebe karamellisiert auch gar
nicht immerhin dem ex an baic mit
karamellsoße genommen im ausland
verschlagen weil man wusste dass schoko
zugenommen hat bei karamellsoße als die
einzige so kann man hier in deutschland
kaufen schreibt die kommentare auch
massive karamell eier auch im
supermarktregal werde einfach überall
das sind halt laufen je nach art merken
sollen
[Musik]
nach kaffee hilft nachlass dass reja gar
nicht nach lache ich glaube dass
lakritze schmeckt lakritz laufen sogar
mit kernel pop also ein lolli mit
kaffeegeschmack also einfach karabel
aufhielt das ist mega deprimieren big
daddy nicht gut von der usa geht es
weiter nach st so schnell kann man
reisen manila
ich muss nicht wegfahren um zu halten
ich mache eine kulinarische reise ich
weiter top karamell etwas besonderes ist
aber hier steht für original an bord als
max mit karamell inkonsistent ist ganz
anders wenn jemand zeit wurde tierisches
karamell
ich liebe meinen job machen wir weiter
mit schokolade mit karamell
derweil fordert karim einfach die beste
erfindung er war jetzt die glühbirne das
auto des internet portals gulli.com
summen ein euro 1 kalender von einem
handy
ich habe immer noch nie bekommen die
anderen hatten selbst gebastelten aber
ins kalender nicht böse ein euro für die
schule habe aber den aufmerksamen
hochwertige schokolade werber
wir wollen ihm ein freund camel seitlich
machen an dem man automatische was
richtig gut die machen schreibt wo alle
in panik geraten weil das so tolle zeit
für chip mit karamell geschmack die
kerle karamell und salz verstanden
das könnte ja super lecker sein oder
auch überschreiten
die bluetooth und vegetarier geeignet
doch mal russland sind die gut und super
genuss prüfen das auto mindestens so
geboten diese ziele geschmacks tomaten
paprika zu schmecken und jetzt manhard
karamell soll auch mit chips schlimm und
wenn man einmal angefangen habe kann man
nicht mehr aufhören nur eine absolute
heizung parlament habt habe ich
irgendwas falsch gemacht aber sie zum
beitrag
so eine karami nicht unterbrochen
[Musik]
auf dem kauf nicht lange und es steckt
ein wunder bei dem großen plan hat die
gleichen zahnfüllung die sogar mit speck
auf den post auch 100 jahre jetzt geht
der kellogg school of time hintergrund
zu gucken
es ist ein spiegel mit karamell und
schokolade
ich möchte zu diesem riga ein gedicht
schreiben sie war schokoriegel meine
drives mit beyond karamell du bist mein
herz und ich liebe denkt und kommen
überall müsse darauf jeweils auch die
arbeit konzentriert und war mit ihnen
link was ist ein ford cup cake von der
gleichen firma die auf twitters machen
ich glaube wenn es im gegensatz zu
künstlichen herben geschmack gibt dann
wäre das vor dem termin okay schon
gänsehaut bekommen je nach geschmack ist
irgendwie seltsam und hat ich spüre man
ganz unten karamell herunter seien wir
mal bei américa mit unserem karamell
apple kauft also karamell april
schwarzen karamell und investor josef
zustand als wir hinten dünner ist als
der markt
das finde ich nicht gut gespannt kommt
es nicht zu mir kam das beste für den
schluss aufbewahrt und waren
dort kamen pritzl stücke mit keller und
barbecue beschlag und sind so riepl
stückl hafenbrücke mit torte karamell
geschmack ist das etwa die hypothetisch
könnte deine flash version entspricht
auch nach drei karamell popcorn aus
gladbach kommt das karamell und auf
platz eins wie könnte es anders sein
sollte
das war meine kleine kulinarische
karamell weltreise ich hoffe euch hat es
gebrannt
wenn ihr auf mehr zu bekommen habt dann
tut es mir sehr leid wenn ich hunger vom
zugucken bekommen habe dann noch mehr
leid und wir sehen uns dann das nächste
mal ich hab euch die folge gefallen und
ich wünsche euch eine schöne woche
denkt dran freudenfeste geschmack der
welt